[Applause]
tiger
is so like you know they always you
always want to compare someone to
michael jordan right yeah
and really the only person you can is
tiger woods there's no one really else
really i mean as far as what they did no
one i don't think anybody
michael and tiger are the same person
and they're
it's they were both the biggest stars of
their things
and they were explaining it to me yeah
yeah well i mean so when tiger came
actually you know being a
black golfer like was not no one there
wasn't that many
there was a there was a lot before him
so it's not like they're not
yeah but it was but when tiger took
tiger took it to another level that
where jordan did where you're like well
just everybody's on board with this guy
we all worship this guy
this guy's the biggest star on earth we
all want to be him they loved what they
do
they like jordan you know like you see
like
jordan lebron right like i was always a
big lebron defender
uh i'm kind of bouncing all over i have
a big theory with kobe too like i missed
out on kobe
because i was too into jordan so that's
our generation
yeah same exact thing jordan kobe was
too close to us that i think
that's my only i wish i would have
appreciated him and watched him because
we saw so much jordan we saw so much
jordan that it was like it was hard too
it was like all right i can't this is
too good i'm watching the same movie i
can't i gotta
but now you look at you're like oh he
was a killer i wish i would have watched
yeah yeah
but i look at uh lebron i was able to
kind of get back into lebron because i
was like i was
i was like a generation removed i go
okay i'll watch this guy yeah yeah
and then so uh but like you see with
lebron and
jordan like jordan like didn't like talk
about himself at all
like he didn't you know lebron starts he
tweets a lot of stuff how great he is
and you're like
you're kind of like all right dude
you're like killing me here like i want
you to be the guy but yeah
jordan's quiet jordan i don't know was
like humble
twitter didn't have twitter yeah which
is humble also got it all yeah
but if you asked him if he was the
greatest he never said yeah like he was
like oh no no the other guys are humble
in that aspect i think he would say he's
the greatest
i think they asked him and he said he
was he goes no it's not the only guy who
could beat me
or could come close to beating me is
kobe because he stole all my moves
yeah when did he say that
not that they asked him we're just gonna
remove jordan from nate and they love
jordan yeah
jordan's not that good he would punch
people in the face that disagree with
him
and practice so there's the social media
aspect i guess that you don't hear
all of this stuff i knew i know he's
aggressive in that way yeah but
but it's but i'm like that's about his
practice is that
actually more tiger-like to me is
they're [ __ ] killers yeah
but everything stays right here yeah and
they don't they didn't have
jordan had a couple friends in the
league tiger didn't have any friends on
tour in his day
he is a he is an island i hear he's
saying with lebron like there's a
weakness to him and
who am i to [ __ ] call lebron week
like he just squats there's no there's
no weakness i just think
if you talk about the two greatest i
think it's uh jordan lebron and then you
can have the conversation outside of
that oh wow i don't like when people
drop people like drop lebron like it's
like garbage i mean
him winning three championships of three
different teams to me if he gets to five
championships that counts as a sixth to
me in the fact that he did it
at three separate teams so now you're
like yeah maybe
you can you could try to say he doesn't
have six he won at three different teams
that's pretty
wild it's hard to build a team around
that's crazy to start over
it's lebron and jordan that's the
conversation yeah and then
it's always funny that no one ever they
always people always say the
championship thing
and you're like oh okay so you're gonna
talk about bill russell like get out of
here i don't talk about bill russell
you're like
well then we're not talking about a
championship thing because he's like
there's there wasn't
any black guys in the league like bill
russell but he won i know games
was there there's one there's a pretty
good one though it was pretty good yeah
pretty good
but there was eight teams like 12 teams
like it was a different okay
it was different but i hear what you're
saying yeah i mean the greatest winner
in history
yeah bill yeah absolutely um but the
lebron thing i don't know when i meant
weakness i meant like um there's like an
emotional weakness there's an ego
weakness and i think that's what you're
talking about
he's trying to prove himself over and
over again no i'm doing good i
am the guy yeah i'm gonna crush you
everybody did it for him
everything i'm saying everybody
everybody like
fans and everybody wrote how great he
was they did it
yeah yeah yeah he didn't come out and go
i'm the greatest yes that's dude like
jordan like that's what i mean by
humbled like i'm not saying he's humbled
yeah but he didn't there was no things
going he would confidently answer a
question
yeah but he never i mean lebron just
tweeted that he's
the 25 points per game thing yeah he
tweeted where everybody was
or he posted it he posted it he's also
teacher report didn't post it yeah he
posted it and he's reacting to people
like yeah it's like you're like
the whole post because it's kind of
funny it was like he said
i don't know i don't y'all never saw me
as a scorer well that's how i wanted it
anyway it's like yeah who was saying
that
he yeah no one he goes today i'm a past
first guy i'm like
yeah dude i think there's an argument
you're the greatest
talent to ever play basketball yeah
uh then once he's better than jordan or
whatever i don't know lebron's no one's
built like that dude no one's that big
and runs that fast and can pass that
good
i mean the core vision it's crazy dude
yeah yeah uh lebron's
it's bananas yeah uh but like jordan
like i don't know it was like
the more you're like you just didn't
hear all the stuff now they did grow up
in two different areas but anyway back
to the jordan tiger thing yeah that's
why they're the exact same
i just don't get tiger well it's crazy
dude you missed out
i i'm just not impressed well that's
insane that falls apart
over golf from [ __ ] like a great book
about
everything a tiger and the documentary
covered a lot of it which is like the
guy was raised to be a [ __ ] killer
his dad damn near gave him ptsd just
like yelling at him
yeah no but it was weird the stuff his
dad was doing was like trying to break
him on the golf course
and he said to tiger if it ever gets to
be too much you say this one word
and i will stop and just say for it it
was safe tiger never used a safe word he
would call him the n word he would like
[ __ ] berate that you yeah [ __ ] you
suck and tiger wouldn't [ __ ] break
this kid
but then he broke he broke with [ __ ] i
mean eventually
[ __ ] break yeah men but he did pretty
good until he broke
i mean but that didn't want a golf
tournament would have broken but if they
would have had
uh you know if like the error that he
would have like all those guys
that guy's unbreakable dude uh if they
doesn't care
different level basketball for two years
he had
a [ __ ] hitler mustache bro yeah
nobody breaks him dude yeah i do
whatever i want to do
however i wanted but he did quit
basketball for two years he retired very
early
and then he came back so that was so he
was broke though
i don't think he was broke i think he
had like some beef in the league i mean
there's a lot of conspiracies about what
that is but i think it was just like oh
you're not going to tell me what i do i
do whatever [ __ ] i want
uh if the tiger thing though so the golf
if you think it's like i know it's like
the idea like how good john daly for
instance
people think he's just this fat guy you
know the hand
and eye coordination he has i saw him
actually play
two weeks ago and we were all hidden in
this kind of this celebrity kind of
thing
and so we're 150 yards from a hole and
there's 200 people watching
and they made all the celebrities hit
just you know to get close to the
hole whatever and if you made it you
would win and so like the
the pressure of hitting with 200 people
watching
is wild all you're thinking is like i
want the ball just to go up there i
don't care if
it goes near it just don't duff it don't
slide it
don't like shank it and so everybody's
hitting
and then john daly goes last pretty
drunk
and he hits it this guy's 50
something years old and dude the ball
just never leaves the flag
it doesn't go in but it just the flags
here the ball
goes directly over the flag
do you know how insane that is dude you
know how hard it is to hit a golf ball
it's so
hard really hard it's really really hard
and it looks like it shouldn't be which
it looks like it's just
training when tiger won that grand slam
where he won
every major and they didn't think that
nobody's done that dude nobody's
his so a handicap what happens when real
athletes start playing golf
though they they can't they do play golf
and they don't do good do they
they do go play golf michael jordan's
played golf his deer in the
nba michael jordan tiger woods and golf
many times
no this is this is this is known dude
yeah
you don't you're just trying to say it
like to go
these are real athletes but they're
learning off late i'm saying what
happens when real athletes go in not
like john daly but like a real app dude
just
dustin johnson phil mickelson's a real
ad he's an accountant all these guys are
accountants like what happens when these
guys that actually have like
you know fast twitch muscle fibers like
real athletes they start playing golf
well they do dustin johnson could have
uh i think could play basketball
somewhere
like in college yeah he could have done
all that he is a real athlete yeah
brooks kevka
these guys didn't tiger change that but
now these guys are all jazzed now
they're [ __ ] jacked now they're in
shape and now they're getting
good at golf finally yeah what tiger did
in his run was unreal handicaps right
yeah so
i'm if i'm a five handicap yeah uh and
then you get to zero with scratch and
then you start going plus
yeah so plus is good so a lot of golfers
are plus five
six seven eight yeah and tiger was at
his best i believe he was a plus ten
so that means every time he goes out to
play it your handicap is basically what
you
ten of the holes he's no under par oh on
yeah yeah if he if he played me then the
rest par rest of the party so
your handicap is what you're capable of
doing yeah so if i'm if i'm a plus five
i can go shoot under par but like i can
also go shoot of 77.
that's what my abilities are right and
then so his
his capability every course that he
walked on yeah if it's a par 71
yeah he can go shoot a 61. that's but
imagine
like antonio brown he could do like a
55. yeah like somebody that actually was
built to do
you know cool physical tom brady here's
why you'll never know because those guys
will never play golf
why well they do go try you watch them
go play fun but they don't
put the same effort in yeah that's what
i'm saying is like what if they put the
exact same effort in
like chess you know it's a sport
but it's more mental than anything it's
chess it's so hard
woods was an athletic chess player yeah
ah
like an astronaut yeah he's an astronaut
gotcha where you have to be physically
fit but you also have to be like smart
mentally strong mentally strong it's uh
it's so hard
that you dismiss it like the way you're
dismissing it that's how hard it is i'll
be honest with you it's like that you're
just acting like you're trying to say
tiger's not good because you're
that's how hard golf is that you just
were like no none of them are good can i
be honest with you sometimes i'll see
my fiance cleaning right actually like
sweeping i'd be like that's golf
yeah yeah that's what i think golf is
yeah it's kind of sweeping something
that's cleaning up the cars
clean it up that's what people tend to
do yeah i think that's
unattainable they go but they don't do
that with stand up right they're like oh
my god that's the hardest thing i would
never want to do that but everybody goes
to the golf and like yeah
everybody wants to do stand-up but
that's the most terrifying thing in the
world like it is the most terrifying but
i mean
there's no celebrity stand-up
tournaments there's a lot of celebrities
that just get into stand-up though like
they're poor now i know but i mean
that's but they go
they go terrify them yeah just let me
turn them it's not like everybody's good
everybody's real bad out there
i'm just trying to say you don't think
that like let's think of an athlete
dwyane wade you don't think of dwayne
ronaldo [ __ ] ronaldo
messi these guys do play and they're
yeah if they if they dedicated they're
it's just different the hand eye open
and whatever they're good at the
pressure and the hand-eye or
coordination all that stuff's like a
little bit better like and that's where
i think golfers come from i mean they're
real they are athletes dude they got to
go
you got to play 18 holes with every hole
is that much pressure
right mentally that's it's just a
different thing dude like
it's yeah it's you're just it's a
different sport
i'll be honest with you i think i could
be uh scratch golf
scratches par yeah if i if i worked on
it for
six months to a year i think i could get
it down if you can get to scratch i'll
give you one hundred thousand dollars
if you can get subscribers if i could be
a scratch goal yeah
i'll give you one hundred thousand
dollars in these guns
i'll do whatever you want like so i
think if i six months a year i would
have to dedicate myself full
like i'd have to at least spend i don't
know i'd have to go go i'll let you do
it every day you have to go
i don't need every day i would go like
maybe on sunday maybe on saturday as
well and then
if i could do it two times a week i
think i could i think i would be a
scratch golfer i'll give you more than a
hundred thousand dollars if i could do
it
the scratch golfer yeah in a year six
months to a year i think between six
months and a year i'd be able to hit it
probably around the nine months
absolutely
absolutely but i don't have to do it at
least two days a week i'd have to do it
i don't know
but i'll get it i'll figure out how you
would give me a million dollars if i
could do that
if you can if you can get to scratch
golf or two
now unless you're lying and i don't know
that you're some golfer or something
that you're
already i'm from new york where would i
golf yeah there's nowhere there's
nowhere to go yes
yeah so six months to a year but if i
just focus on it like if i actually went
there and i like looked at the ball and
i tried to hit it straight i think i
could do that
yeah absolutely he also thinks he can
beat ronda rousey in a ufc
yeah i mean yeah i could definitely do
that i think that akash could also do
that
yeah yeah i'm not i'm not on board with
this one she beat turtle in entourage so
i doubt it
wait in an actual fight or the entourage
the show oh it was the show
okay cause then i was about i was about
to think about that yeah because he's
littler
but he's still a guy yeah yeah all right
i mean look i don't want to like ruin
golf for you or anything like that i'm
just saying
it's not i mean you're not ruining you
won't ruin it for me i love how much
you'll be rewarded by it yeah because
you don't
uh because i actively do play every day
trying to get to
zero and you also have like you have
like a golf thing right yeah
so that's oh yeah dude and i can't do it
what do you mean i can't get to zero i
think you could get to zero
have you tried playing one two times
already i actually need a million
i gotta give you a million okay
i need something
you